REBECCA MOORE: Good morning and
welcome to Maps for Good,
or what I think of as
maps that matter.
Because it turns out that maps
are not only useful for
navigating from point A to point
B, but can also be very
powerful tools to make the
world a better place.
My name is Rebecca Moore.
I'm engineering manager at
Google for Google Earth
Outreach and Google
Earth Engine.
And I'm pleased to have on the
panel Dave Thau, who's
developer advocate for Earth
Engine, and two of our lead
developers from nonprofit
partner organizations, Kevin
Bluer from Access Map and Jake
Wall from Save the Elephants.
Developers have a very important
role to play in
leveraging Google Earth,
Google Maps, all of our
mapping tools, to make the world
a better place, working
with nonprofits.
For me this all started
personally back in 2005 in my
community in the Santa
Cruz mountains.
Google Earth had just come
out two months earlier.
I opened the mail, and this
is what I received.
My neighbors and I got
this map in the mail.
What does it say?
Notice of intent to
harvest timber.
This is in the Santa Cruz
mountains above Las Gatos.
The legend says, hmm,
non-industrial timber
management plan area is bordered
by black lines.
Not terribly helpful.
There are helicopter landing
sites that are circles.
I'm a map person, you're
all map people.
But you can imagine that this
was difficult for most of my
neighbors to understand.
And so most of them simply
threw it out.
They just threw out this public
notice, which was maybe
the intent of the senders.
But I was concerned because
logging did not
sound like a good idea.
And so I thought, what would
happen-- and again, Google
Earth had just come out
two months earlier--
if instead of this black and
white map, I tried to figure
out the elements of this plan
and remapped it instead on
Google Earth?
So first I found this location
on Google Earth, and
it looks like this.
Well, that's immediately a
whole lot more helpful to
understand what's going on.
And then, as I said, I took
those elements of the plan,
and I remapped it.
From this, I was personally
shocked.
And when I showed it to my
neighbors, they were shocked
because it became evident that
this was a very long, five
mile long swath of over 1,000
acres of old growth redwoods
that would be cut where the
logging would go right up next
to schools, day care center,
elementary school.
Helicopters would be landing and
taking off in perpetuity
over these playgrounds
and so on.
Just having the high-resolution
data and the
spatial information together
made that much more clear.
Of course, seeing it in
3D is even better.
And using SketchUp models of
helicopters, again, this could
make clear to people
what was at stake.
So I was a little bit
like Al Gore.
It was right in that period of
an Inconvenient Truth when Al
Gore was going around giving
slide shows everywhere.
I was trudging, not through the
snow, but trudging around
to different communities, to the
media, to politicians who
wanted to understand this plan
better than they could from
those grainy black and white
maps and a 400 page plan.
And in fact, what people stated,
and you can see this
here, has come up again and
again and again since then.
Things like, I thought I was
well informed until I looked
at this in Google Earth.
And this three-dimensional
presentation gave an amazing
topographic bird's-eye view
of how invasive the
logging will be.
So that began the sort
of seeing is
believing for public benefit.
The media picked this
up as well.
SPEAKER 1: Well, tonight, a
battle is brewing in the South
Bay over plans to log
1,000 acres of land.
Tony Russomanno shows us exactly
what's at stake.
SPEAKER 2: We're taking a Google
Earth virtual flyover
along a five mile length of
Los Gatos Creek between
Lexington Reservoir
and Lake Elsman in
the Santa Cruz mountains.
The area in red, totaling 1,000
acres, is land that San
Jose Water Company
wants to log.
The map was created by a
software engineer who lives in
the area, and it's being used to
galvanize opposition to the
company's plan.
REBECCA MOORE: The point was
instead of it being abstract
roads and so on, you could see
it with your own eyes.
And it changed an abstract
concept to something that was
quite concrete.
Eventually, using Google Earth,
we were able to prove
that this logging plan was not
only a bad idea but it was in
fact illegal.
And to my knowledge this was
the first grassroots
environmental application
of Google Earth.
So we stopped the logging,
and now in fact--
[APPLAUSE]
REBECCA MOORE: Thank you.
Yay!
And now, in fact, the area is
being considered for public
open space and permanent
protection.
So that started getting a lot
of attention around the
blogosphere and media.
The Wall Street Journal wrote
this article, "Activists Start
Googling: Internet Maps
Illustrate Environmental
Woes." People were saying,
instead of climbing trees and
doing tree sits,
environmentalists are sitting
in front of Google Earth, and
that's how they're making a
difference.
People started writing to me.
And I was just a
Google engineer
working on Google Earth.
But all of these environmental
groups all over the world
started writing to me saying,
can you teach us what you did
so we can do the same thing?
So I started Google Earth
Outreach, our program to help
nonprofits, as a 20% project.
It's grown.
Members of our team are here.
We've worked with
more than 2,000
nonprofits around the world.
And it turns out that although
they are able to use our
tutorials, and they are doing
a lot of fantastic work on
their own, some of them need
help from professional
developers like you guys.
So, by the way, that's
our URL.
Please check it out.
So back in 2011, we started a
Developer Grants program where
we specifically awarded $10,000
to $20,000 to a number
of nonprofits, actually 16
different nonprofits, to
dedicate to hiring developers
to build these cutting edge
visualizations of their campaign
in Google Earth.
These are some of the projects
that have come out
in this last year.
I love the Atlantic
Public Media.
You should check it out.
Who would think that you would
get emotional about Arctic
turn migration?
But I guarantee you it will
bring a tear to your eye.
So again, I encourage you
to check this out.
You can imagine that if we did
a round of grants in 2011,
there may be an announcement we
have coming up at the end
of the talk today.
So please stay tuned.
I'm just going to show you a
couple of these projects that
resulted from the developer
grants in 2011.
And here's one.
Eyes on the Forest with World
Wildlife Federation.
The developer is David Tryse.
They're using Google Maps
Engine-- and we now have a
grants program to give Google
Maps Engine for free to
registered nonprofits--
to show the change in forests
that's happening in Sumatra
and how that relates to
shrinking tiger habitat.
All these data layers
are in Maps Engine.
So looking at these two,
the green area
is 1990 forest cover.
And the orange surrounded
grey area is
suitable tiger habitat.
You can see there's a very
strong correlation between
forest and tiger habitat.
Then you can see in 2000, the
forest cover is shrinking.
And you can see the tiger
habitat now is exposed where
there's no forest.
Let's go a little further
forward in time.
2007, further shrinking
in forest.
This is rampant deforestation
in Sumatra due to palm oil
plantations.
So finally, that's where
we are in 2009.
And now if you project
where tigers can now
live, it's like that.
So this is a very visual way to
illustrate the driving of
species toward extinction by
virtue of land use changes.
A second really important
project, this is by the Halo
Trust, which is a nonprofit
organization dedicated to
eradicating landmines
around the world.
They use Google Earth Pro to
document which areas still
have mines and are dangerous and
need to be cleared-- you
see those in red--
and which areas have been
cleared in green and are safe
for people to return.
Here's an example in 2002
in Kunji, Angola.
These areas in red were
too dangerous.
And you can see the area
is not settled at all.
No one lives near there because
of these dangers.
Now fast forward to 2011.
Those areas have been cleared
of landmines and now people,
villages, are returning.
It's safe for children
to walk to school.
With their developer grant,
they built a Google Earth
tour, an animated tour that's
actually narrated by Angelina
Jolie, that shows more than 70
million land mines on the
border between Cambodia and
Thailand and makes very
evident what's at stake and why
these issues are important.
More than 70,000 displaced
people could return to their
homes after these mines
were cleared.
And today they're growing wheat,
vegetables, and grapes.
The last example I want to show
you before turning it
over is cultural mapping.
I think this is a really
important future frontier if
you guys are interested
in indigenous culture.
There are thousands of tribes
all over the world who are not
on Google Earth and
Maps today.
Their cultures are
not well mapped.
And many of them would like
to get on the map.
So in particular, Chief Almir
Surui from the Brazilian
Amazon approached us in 2007 and
asked us if we would help
document the illegal invasions
of his territory that were
happening and help them put
their culture on the map.
Working with our team, also with
an outside developer, we
just launched this
a week or so ago.
Almost 300 place marks that tell
where they hunt, where
they fish, where they gather the
wood for their arrows, the
site of first contact.
It's narrated, some of the
tours, by the Surui youth.
And I can tell you that tribes
all over the world are
contacting us because they
want to do the same.
So if you as developers are
interested in that, please
come talk to us.
So to wrap it up, what are the
themes that we've been seeing
in these first few years
of Maps for Good?
First of all is seeing
is believing.
You can show a politician charts
and graphs, and their
eyes glaze over.
But you show them the issue in
Google Earth and Maps, and in
a minute, they can get the
issue, and you can make a
change in policy.
Groups like Halo Trust are using
it to actually run their
day to day operations.
And finally, maybe the biggest
thing, is people are using it
to raise awareness, to inspire
donors, to inspire volunteers,
and actually make the world
a better place.
So with that, we're going
to turn it over.
You're going to hear from Dave
Thau, who is going to talk
about a next-generation platform
that our team has
developed called Google
Earth Engine, which is
petabyte-scale analysis of
satellite imagery, Kevin
Bluer, who is going to talk
about Axis Map, and Jake Wall.
Take it away, Dave.
DAVE THAU: Thanks Rebecca.
So I'm Dave Thau.
I'm developer advocate on Google
Earth Engine, which
means my job is to work with
developers who are creating
applications to run on the Earth
Engine platform, which
I'll tell you about now.
This is Google Earth.
So who here uses Google Earth?
Yeah, all right.
So you know it's a great
application for visualizing
data and also collaborating.
But one thing it's not really
designed for is doing analysis
of earth data.
And we've gotten feedback from
people saying, hey Google.
You have a lot of geodata and a
lot of computational power.
Why don't you give us the tools
that we need to be able
to do analysis on your data?
And that's what Earth Engine
was developed for.
So let me give you
some examples of
what I mean by analysis.
For one, the United Nations,
last week, had a conference on
sustainable development.
One of the questions there is,
how can we minimize the
environmental impact of growing
our population by two
billion people?
And one of the approaches to
that is to only develop in
places that are already
developed.
Don't develop in new places.
So if there's not a road
someplace, don't start
sticking roads there.
So leading up to the conference,
we were approached
by a member of the European
Parliament
who said, hey Google.
You have lots of road data.
Can you create for us a map
of the roadless areas?
And so we used the tool box that
we've been creating to
create this map.
So this is a map globally of
all the areas that are one
kilometer away from
roads or nearer.
So the white areas are
the ones that are
right on the roads.
And then there's a gradient
that goes off from there.
So you can see down in Brazil,
there are lots of areas that
don't have roads.
But then there are these funny
little guys down here.
These are little road networks
that are disconnected from
everything.
So it's kind of interesting.
What's going on there?
And you also can easily see that
places like Alaska, where
you think that there are lots
of places where there are no
roads, are highly developed.
So there are lots
of roads here.
So at a glance, you can look at
this map and find out where
the roadless areas are.
And this involved analyzing all
of road data that we have,
which is millions of kilometers
of roads.
So another kind of analysis is
deforestation detection.
So here is the Surui territory
that Rebecca mentioned.
You can see that it's pretty
well protected.
This is their territory.
All this is deforestation.
And you can see on the edge,
there are little incursions of
deforestation.
And so you might want to ask,
when did those get there?
Are they growing?
How fast are they growing?
And these are good
questions to ask.
And you need to have access
to data to answer them.
Now there's a underutilized
feature in Google Earth, which
is the Historical Data button,
a little globe up
here with an arrow.
And with this, when you click
on this in Google Earth, you
get a timeline.
And you can actually go back to
historical data that's in
Google Earth.
But these are snapshots.
They're really nice images
that we've gotten from
satellites.
But it's only every
once in a while.
So this picture was
taken in 2009.
Here's the next earliest
one, a couple of
months earlier in 2008.
And then going back in
time, this is the
earliest image we have.
So it's hard to look at those
data and be able to answer the
questions like, how fast
is it growing and
when did it get there?
And so this is what we've
developed Earth Engine for, to
give developers the ability
to ask those questions.
So here's the Earth engine
in a nutshell.
There are a couple components.
One is we've been downloading
lots of satellite data and
other sorts of data sets that
you might want access to.
And I'll talk about
that in a second.
On top of those data, we have
an API that lets you
programmatically access
the data and run
algorithms using it.
And when you run the algorithms,
they run on the
Google cluster.
And also using the API, you
can build applications.
So we have some applications
that we ourselves have built,
and we're also working with
science partners and NGOs to
build other applications.
So here's a little bit about
the data that we have.
We've been downloading entire
sets of satellite data.
There is a series of satellites
called Landsat that
have been going since 1972, and
we've been acquiring that
whole catalog.
So we have 40 years of
historical data.
Most of it is daily data,
so daily up to 40 years.
We're getting the satellite
data as it comes in daily.
And we have other data sets.
So we have elevation data,
atmospheric data.
And as developers need more data
to do analyses that they
think are important, we will be
adding those data as well.
Now an interesting thing about
the data is it's full
satellite data.
So in Google Earth, what you
see is red, green, blue
imagery taken from lots of
different kinds of satellites,
but cleaned up and nicely
displayed so it
looks really good.
What we have in Earth Engine
is the raw satellite data.
And you can do interesting
things with it.
So here we have the
electromagnetic spectrum,
ready for science.
So here's some low wavelength
electromagnetic spectrum and
it goes down to radio waves,
which are longer wavelengths.
And the visible spectrum, where
red, green, and blue
live, are in the middle.
So the satellites that we tend
to use, use not only the
visible spectrum, but also a
lot of stuff in infrared.
So Landsat, which I mentioned,
has eight bands, Landsat 7, so
I'll talk about just
some of them.
So the first three bands are
blue, green, and red.
So that's what you see
in Google Earth.
But then in addition there
are infrared bands.
And there's also
thermal bands.
So you can measure heat.
So what's nice about this is you
can combine these bands in
various ways to see things you
wouldn't normally see if you
just had RGB.
So let's just take RGB.
Here's an image around
Yosemite.
If you haven't been to Yosemite,
go to Yosemite.
It's stunning.
It looks a lot better
than this.
This is recent.
This is taken not so long ago.
Actually, no, this is a little
bit more towards the winter.
But it's hard to see
what's going on.
There is the snow.
There are clouds.
Somewhere in here
there's land.
But it's hard to see, right?
If you're interested in
vegetation, you can't really
get it from this.
But if you're interested in
vegetation, you can look at a
combination of these bands,
the red band and
in the near IR band.
And when you do that, the
vegetation pops out.
So from the same image, using
these different bands, you can
see the vegetation here, the
less vegetation here, and no
vegetation here.
And similarly, if you're
interested in snow and water,
you can use a different
set of bands, and snow
and water pop out.
So with this additional
information and the ability to
analyze it, you can get to a
lot of features that you
weren't able to with just RGB.
Now that's the data.
Now to analyze the data, to
access it, we have an API that
we're building.
The API is currently in
trusted tester mode.
I'll give you an email address
to write to if you're
interested in testing it out.
So this is not the actual API.
This is a pseudo code.
But we have to APIs,
a JavaScript one
and a Python one.
And here's an example of the
kinds of things you can do
pretty easily.
So here's Landsat 7.
I'm grabbing the Landsat
7 catalog here.
I'm filtering it down
to just 2011 here.
And here I'm doing something
pretty cool, I'm taking the
median of every pixel in
the stack of images.
So Landsat 7 circles around
every 16 days or so.
So in a given year,
you might get 20
images of the same spot.
So here's the Bay Area.
So you get 20 images
stacked up.
And for each pixel in each
band, you figure out the
median value, and you bring
it up to the top.
So that's what median does.
And that helps change
an image from this.
So this is kind of a noisy
Landsat 7 image.
There are funny stripes, there
are clouds, there are all
kinds of stuff going on.
Just by applying median and
displaying it on map, you get
a much cleaner image.
And so there you go.
Four commands cleans up this
and gives you this.
And the nice thing about the API
is it's designed to run in
parallel in the Google cluster,
and that lets us
scale very well.
So show you how that works.
Let's say you want to do some
deforestation detection on an
image like this.
What we do is we divide the
image up into little bits, and
then we farm it out to lots
of different computers.
And if you went to the keynote,
you can imagine how
many computers you could farm
these things out to.
600,000 cores, yes.
Then you process the image
and recombine it.
And you're done.
So this allows us to scale to
very large, from states to
countries, to continents,
to global analyses.
One of the things we did was
this Mexico forest map.
This is the highest resolution
map of forests in
Mexico right now.
The Mexican government
is validating it.
It was 18 terabytes of data.
It took 15,000 hours to compute,
which would be years
on a single CPU if nothing
went wrong.
And it always does.
But if took us less
than a day.
It took about 14 hours because
we were able to spread it out
over lots of computers.
And the analysis--
we worked with our science
partner Matt
Hanson to do this.
So it's his algorithms
to compute it.
And it took data--
here's Cancun.
It took data that looked
like this.
So this is actual Landsat 7
data, clouds, missing data.
It's a mess.
And turns it into this.
So this gives you much clearer
idea of where the
forest is in this area.
So that's one example
of things we can do.
We're also building
applications.
So we have some of our own,
and we're working with
partners to develop others.
And they are using the
API to do that.
So here's one application
that we're building.
It's a classification engine.
You can create mosaics,
composites of Landsat data.
And then you can train
up a classifier.
So we're piggybacking
off the Google
prediction API for this.
You can plop down some
points, some classes.
So this is forest.
This is not forest.
You can upload data sets.
You can upload already
classified images.
And then you choose a
classifier, so [INAUDIBLE]
phase, and you hit Classify.
And then in seconds, you
get a classified map.
So this is an application that
we're rolling out through
trusted testers also.
And the email address I'll
give you will give
you access to this.
And the last thing I'll talk
about is an application that
we're building with an
NGO called Imazon.
So Imazon is doing deforestation
monitoring in
the Amazon.
They have monthly reports that
they issue with how much
deforestation is happening, and
they're a watchdog group
that compares their results to
the Brazilian government.
They have a desktop system
they've been using.
But it takes about a month to
do a month's analysis, and
it's just the Brazilian
Amazon.
So they want to scale it up.
They want to scale it
to the rest of the
Amazon and more globally.
And to do that they've ported
it over to Earth Engine.
Next month, they're shifting
completely over, and they're
going to be doing the reporting
from Earth Engine.
This an application we've
built with them,
built on the API.
It's an HTML5 application.
It uses canvas.
You can do things like change
thresholding to change the
sensitivity for deforestation
and degradation detection.
And it's pretty snazzy.
And they say it's cutting their
time for analysis in
half from what they
have already.
So to close, Earth Engine gives
you lots of satellite
imagery and lots of other kinds
of data that you might
want to use in analyses, and API
for analyzing those data,
and the ability to run it
over the Google cluster.
Thanks very much.
If you want to play with the
API and that classifier,
here's the email address
to write to.
If you do write to it, please
give some description of what
you'd like to do.
We're still working out the
details of the API.
So we're rolling it out slowly
to trusted testers.
So if you give us an idea of
what you want to do, that
would be great.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVE THAU: Now I'll turn things
over to Jason Dasilva
who will talk about
AXS Maps, another
Mapping for Good project.
JASON DASILVA: Hi, my name is
Jason Dasilva, and I'm the
founder of AXS Map.
I have multiple sclerosis,
and getting
around can be a challenge.
So I came up with an idea.
Hi.
My name is Jason, and I use
a scooter to get around.
It's not so easy.
I have trouble going to stores,
finding bathrooms that
are accessible, and meeting
up with friends.
Of course, I can call ahead.
But many places say they're
accessible, but really,
they're not.
There has to be a better way.
So I had an idea.
What if everyone could
share all the
accessible places they know?
And what if all this was put on
one map, and that map was
available on the web
and mobile phones?
I call it AXS Map, an online
and mobile app where anyone
can search for accessible places
or review them on their
entry ways or bathrooms.
AXS Map opens up a whole
new world of choices.
And I can instantly find all the
accessible places around
me, where to eat, shop, grab
a coffee, or get a haircut.
Even if you're not in a
wheelchair, you're invited to
give ratings and contribute.
AXS Map is powered by you.
The more you review, the better
it gets for people with
canes, walkers, or wheelchairs,
even moms and
dads with strollers.
AXS Map is your ticket
to mobility freedom.
It's easy and free to use.
Help make this world a
more inclusive one.
Join the movement today.
Check it out.
AxsMap.com.
So that's AXS Map.
And just to give you a little
bit of context, accessibility
is not just about convenience.
It's a human right.
And with that, I'm going to hand
you over to the developer
of AXS Map, Kevin Bluer.
KEVIN BLUER: OK.
Hi guys.
My name is Kevin Bluer.
And as you just saw, that was
Jason Dasilva, who's the
founder of AXS Map.
And as he mentioned, I'm
one of the developers.
So I'm just going to start with
a few screenshots of AXS
Map, just to give you a flavor
of what we've built.
So here is the search
results screen.
On the left, you can see
the results, obviously.
There are kind of two measures
there, so getting into a
venue, and then once you're
inside, the restrooms.
They're the kind of
two key measures.
And we'll go into some
more in a moment.
And on the right, you can
obviously see the map.
That's actually Jason's
neighborhood in Williamsburg,
Brooklyn, in New York.
And already you can see
a few colored pins
there, which is great.
One of the goals of this is to
actually be able to see before
you go or while you're on the
go, as well as seeing venues
that are accessible
around you.
This is a venue page.
And as you can see, in terms of
the same results, the two
kind of key measures.
So getting into that venue and
once you're inside, as I
mentioned, the rest rooms.
We've got six additional
attributes in the middle of
the screen there, these six
tiles that you can kind of
click on when you're
adding a review.
And that's things like spacious,
once you're inside
the venue, whether they've got
an accessibility ramp,
accessible parking, Braille
menus, et cetera.
In the top right as well, you
can see we've embedded Google
Street View.
Which I know Jason used to use
prior to this tool existing
just to get a glimpse from the
outside just to see how
accessible the venue is.
Now it's sort of embedded
in this tool.
So a great use of Street
View there.
This is just adding a review.
Quite simply, you can see the
kind of bigger emphasis on
kind of chunkier icons to make
the actual application a
little more accessible.
And you got the stars and the
tiles when he you're adding a
review, and then obviously
comments.
And then this, lastly, in terms
of the examples of the
screen, so it's a little slow.
OK, yeah.
And this is just the
mobile app as well.
We have both a mobile web
version and an Android version
and an iOS version in
the works. too.
And you can kind of see we've
got parity there between the
main web and mobile web and
native apps as well.
So stepping back in terms of
building the application, in
terms of the kind of setting up
some of the goals when we
sat down to build this.
We obviously wanted to
make the application
easy to use, of course.
Broad appeal, so as Jason
mentioned in the animation
there, everything from a
mother or father with a
stroller, through to someone,
a user of a wheelchair.
And then actually making the
application itself accessible.
So we've kind of got a big
emphasis on bigger kind of
fonts and icons, as you saw in
some of the screens, white on
black fonts.
Going for a big emphasis on
compliance, WCAG compliance in
the actual app itself.
In terms of when we were
building it as well, we
actually built out a number of
interactive wire frames, used
Balsamiq Mockups.
I don't know if you guys are
familiar with that, but that's
a great tool for actually kind
of mocking up the application.
We actually got Jason using the
app and some of the other
folks in the community to
actually sort of play around
with it before we started
to build.
So that was very useful.
In terms of the technology stack
as well, on the back
end, in terms of the API that
we call, on the Google side,
we use Places API.
As you saw, we use the Maps.
We've embedded Street
View as well.
So a great use of
great services.
In terms of our stack,
it's MongoDB,
node for the web server.
And we also have our own
API, which I'll come to
in a moment as well.
And in terms of the clients,
for the web clients, usual
suspects, so HTML5,
CSS, and script.
And for the native Apps, we
actually used PhoneGap, or as
it's now called since it's been
open sourced, Cordova,
which I'll come to in
a moment as well.
In terms of some of the
technical design decisions
when we're building the tool,
I mentioned we're using node
on the web server, so app
server, which essentially led
us to having JavaScript
everywhere.
It was my first project with
node, personally, and a great
experience.
Obviously this is a technical
crowd, so I'm sure a lot of
you have familiarity with it.
And yeah, it was great.
There's definitely something to
be said for the elegance of
having JavaScript across the
board right through to the
data that comes out of the Mongo
database in this case.
And in terms of Cordova or
PhoneGap as well, again,
personally it was my first
experience with it.
But it was a great stack.
And I think one of the takeaways
there was it really
depends on the application.
And if you're not familiar with
it, it's just a framework
that allows you to port web
languages-- so your markups,
script, style sheets, and so
on-- into native applications.
You can the sensors
on the hardware
through that framework.
As mentioned, we have
an API as well.
This is one of the key things
to communicate today.
It's got kind of two
core elements.
So we have essentially an
augmentation layer on top of
the Google Places API.
So any call that's made to our
API, we're in turn calling the
Google Places API and then
looking up to see if we have
any accessibility data on
that particular venue.
And if we do, then we return
that on top and take a little
snippet of the JSON response
that we inject in there.
So things like all the kind
of things you saw earlier.
So getting in, the one to five,
and restrooms, one to
five, and so on.
And key takeaway is we'd
love to share this.
So if there's any need to
embed accessibility
information into your
applications, feel free to
reach out to us.
My email address is up there.
And feel free to come
and chat after.
We'd love to integrate
this into Apps.
It's one of the kind
of goals as Jason
mentioned at the start.
Just to close, in an upcoming
release, we have an immediate
term release where we're going
to be adding photo upload and
richer filters, which will allow
you to take pictures of
key accessibility points as you
are going out and mapping
venues within cities
and so on.
And in terms of the filters as
well, so you can actually kind
of query it to say show me a
venue that has Braille menus
in a 50-meter radius
around me.
We also have a number
of tweaks around the
accessibility of the app that
we're going to be releasing.
And on the right hand side of
the screen, we've just added a
number of the kind of more of
the blue sky things that we
would like to do in the more
medium to long term.
This first one there
is visualization.
So to answer questions, such
as, how accessible is your
neighborhood or city?
To compare those is
a big win for us.
And as we're building this
data set that's becoming
something feasible that we can
actually start to answer.
And the top right there, we've
got augmented reality.
So we actually kind of did build
a quick prototype of an
AR interface.
So you can kind of see
the cool demos there.
But in this case, you can
actually see the venues
hovering around you and their
degree of accessibility.
So that's pretty neat.
And then finally gamification,
so adding game mechanics and
incentivization mechanics to the
application just to make
it a little bit more sticky.
So that's it from me.
Yeah, so as I said, definitely
reach out after.
I would love to chat and look at
maybe getting accessibility
into your applications.
So with that, I'm going to hand
over to Jake Wall from
Save the Elephants.
So thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
JAKE WALL: So good afternoon.
So my name's Jake Wall, and I'm
a researcher from a group
called Save the Elephants
in Kenya.
So Save the Elephants is
primarily a conservation group
but with a strong focus on
scientific research.
For the last 15 years,
our group has
been studying elephants.
And through the lens of science,
we're trying to paint
a picture of what elephants
need to
survive on this planet.
A central focus has been on
movement ecology of elephants
and includes looking at home
range, migratory patterns, and
other spatial behaviour.
And to do this, we do
a lot of mapping.
So to follow the movements of
elephants, we use GPS tracking
collars, which we fit around
the neck of an elephant.
It's basically an indestructible
box.
It carries a GPS receiver,
lithium battery, and since
2004, it carries a cell phone.
And here you can see a bull
elephant called Yeager
sniffing old collars
in our camp.
So the Elephant needs to be
tranquilized in order to fit
the collar.
Once the collar's been put on,
though, it can generally last
for up to five years.
And it takes positions
generally every hour.
So think of your cell phone
making a call every hour for
five years.
The real time tracking has
opened up all kinds of new
opportunities for elephant
conservation.
And today I'm going to show you
the system that we built
to track elephants
in real time.
So first I want to mention
three of the
challenges to our system.
One was that the data
had to be secure.
So we needed password
authentication.
Because of the poaching that's
going on now of African
elephants, there's a real threat
to elephants if this
information was to get out.
The second is at that the
data needed to be as
real time as possible.
So for management or
conservation action, we need
data as it occurs.
And the third was that there's
multiple tiers of
users of our system.
So on one side, we have
scientific researchers who
need the data as it is, as it
comes off the elephant.
On the other side, there's
members of the public who
maybe are interested in
education and learning about
elephants but don't need
the actual real
time location of elephants.
We had to build the system
to encompass all of that.
So here's our tracking system.
It's a little confusing.
Basically, on the left side,
we have our data inputs.
So these are collars, so
elephants wearing collars.
Here we have a cloud server,
which ingests the data.
We store it in a Postgres
database.
And then on the right
side, we have users.
So we've got different--
so wildlife managers, rangers,
and administrator, researcher.
So animal link is our primary
software that ingests data
from the different collars.
And then we have a movement
monitor software, an events
monitor software, which
looks for anything
strange with the data.
So it can alert us if an
elephant stopped moving or has
crossed a fence line,
et cetera.
So there are several different
tasks that it performs.
So what I'll do is walk you
through the lifetime of a GPS
fix from the collar to our
system and to the user.
So say we've got a collar
here on an elephant,
and it takes a fix.
It sends that fix via the local
cell phone network in
Kenya via TCP/IP.
And then our animal
link software is
listening on that port.
And it ingests any data that
it reads in from that port.
And it stores it in the animal
tracking database.
It then tries to parse the
data for coordinates and
stores the location data into
the animal tracking database.
At this point, users of Google
Earth can query our KML
tracking service which
is running.
So any user of Google Earth can
connect via the tracking
service, which then queries the
database and turns the raw
coordinate data into KML
and sends it back to
the user like that.
So we're using a Windows
Communication Foundation data
contract as the basis
for this.
So here we have what's called a
data structure service and a
tracking service.
So the data structure service
defines the number of nodes in
the tree, and I'll show you that
in a second, whereas the
tracking service is what
actually gives you real time
tracking data.
So within our system Google
Earth has become an essential
geovisualization tool.
Although it might seem a simple
idea, transformation of
raw coordinates into a movement
trajectory that can
be visualized and replayed in
the context of terrain,
vegetation, and human
infrastructure is an
incredibly powerful tool.
This wasn't at all easy
until the release of
Google Earth in 2005.
And we've had a close
partnership with
Google since then.
As Rebecca said, seeing
is believing.
So I'm now going to show
you a live demo of
our tracking service.
So here's our tracking
service.
And this is all coming live
from our cloud server.
So when I click on this link,
it's going to generate KML.
And you saw how quickly
that was.
So that's querying the database,
and it's creating
KML tracks for all these
elephants in real time.
And we're not just confined
to elephants actually.
We've got a number of
different species.
But I'll show you one
of our elephants.
So we're going to look now at
an elephant called Mountain
Bull who's become
famous recently.
He was the star of a BBC film.
And here he is.
So if I click on his data.
And this is all temporal
data, so I can use
the time slider feature.
And this is the real
time location.
So within the last hour.
So we're zoomed into an area
of Kenya right now.
And he's--
actually some really interesting
behavior here.
What he's done is he's walked up
to-- this is the main Cape
to Cairo highway.
And you can see how he's hit
the highway and he's
come back from it.
And he's probably going to wait
until night time before
he crosses that highway.
So that's the real time location
of a bull elephant in
Kenya at this moment.
So an interesting note about
this elephant and why I chose
him was that a few
years ago, he was
accused of crop raiding.
So in Kenya right now, there's
a problem with human/wildlife
conflict and wildlife living on
the margins of places where
people are growing
crops and so on.
And Mountain Bull was accused
of crop raiding.
And we quickly got onto Google
Earth and were able
to pull up his track.
And the Kenya Wildlife Service
in certain cases has the
option to destroy an animal if
they've found that they've
been very harmful to people.
But we were able to get onto
Google Earth and check out his
track and prove that he was not
the elephant in question,
that he had been nowhere near
the farms in question.
And so we got him
off the hook.
And he lives to this day.
So that was very good.
So let me switch back.
And there's Mountain Bull.
So that's the bull
you've just seen.
So our KML tracking service is
therefore used by everyone
from rangers on patrol in Kenya
to researchers studying
behavior in a university and
has become an essential
conservation tool.
Globally, technology is playing
a bigger role in
wildlife conservation
management.
Software, databases, and sensors
are the new notebook,
pen, and binoculars
for field work.
Through continued partnership
with companies like Google
that have a global conscience
and the resources to make
things happen, we hope
to continue to
save elephants together.
Thank you.
And I'll pass it back
to Rebecca.
[APPLAUSE]
REBECCA MOORE: Thanks, Jake.
Yeah, I think about Brian
McClendon, one of the
inventors of Keyhole that
became Google Earth.
Would he have ever imagined
that a few years in the
future, it would be used to save
an elephant from being
falsely accused of crop crime?
So we're going to end by
announcing here today the 2012
round of Google Earth Outreach
developer grants.
Here's how it works.
The grants are in the range
of $10,000 to $20,000.
The goal is to help support
developers and nonprofits in
building cutting edge
applications that both drive
the state of the art of mapping
technology and also
advance some public benefit
purpose in a new way.
So how does it work?
It's actually the nonprofit
organizations who apply.
We've found that the ones that
are most successful in getting
approved actually have a
relationship with a developer.
So they're able to put
together a thoughtful
application.
The funding that goes to those
grants that are awarded is
100% dedicated to
the developers.
So what should you do?
Well, if you already have some
kind of relationship with a
nonprofit organization, you
have an idea together of
something you might want to
work on, by all means
encourage them.
And work with them to put
together a proposal.
The deadline is August
1 for this round.
If you don't specifically have
a project in mind or a
relationship with a nonprofit,
but you're interested in
working in this space, we
highly encourage you to
register yourself, your
portfolio, your skills, your
interests in our developer
marketplace.
This is where we direct
non-profits to go when they're
looking for a developer.
I'll show you more about
that in a second.
For those of you who are here at
I/O, please come talk to us
at the Develop for Good booth
that's right nearby
here on floor two.
And you can meet with our team,
you can talk with Jake
and Kevin and get more
information and maybe
brainstorm ideas for this
round of grants.
So getting in the developer
marketplace, there's the URL.
This is on our Earth
Outreach site.
It's a pretty straightforward
process.
We're going to fast track those
developer marketplace
applications that are coming in
now so that you can be in
there for nonprofits in this
round of grants to consider
your services.
So with that, thank
you very much for
coming to Maps for Good.
And hopefully, you're a little
bit inspired to help make the
world a better place
through mapping.
Please join me in thanking
everyone on the panel.
[APPLAUSE]
REBECCA MOORE: We do have a few
minutes if you have questions.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: We have a lot
of orthographic data
that we've paid for.
And is it possible to submit
that into the database that
Google has?
REBECCA MOORE: Yeah.
A couple options there.
One is Maps Engine,
which is hosting
your data in the cloud.
So if you are a nonprofit, you
can apply for a free grant of
Google Maps Engine and
upload your own data.
If you want to contribute it to
Google, there are ways to
do that, to contribute data.
And we can talk more about that
offline, if you want.
AUDIENCE: Great.
The second question is do
you support LIDAR data?
REBECCA MOORE: Depends what
you mean by support.
So LIDAR data, when it's
originally captured, it's this
3D point cloud.
But that's often not what people
do the analysis on.
You can convert that 3D point
cloud into a raster data set.
And yes, that raster
data set can be
analyzed in Earth Engine.
AUDIENCE: So we would need
to convert it to
the raster data set.
REBECCA MOORE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
REBECCA MOORE: For now.
AUDIENCE: This is [INAUDIBLE]
from Hong Kong.
And I would like to know
if there is any
restriction for NGOs.
Do they need to reside in
the states or can it be
all over the world?
REBECCA MOORE: That's
a great question.
As we launch Google Earth
Outreach in different
countries, we need to determine
what constitutes a
legally registered charity
in that country.
So for now we've launched in
the US, Brazil, all over
Europe, all over Africa.
We have some launches coming
up in Asia later this year.
But if you go to our Earth
Outreach site, you can see
which countries were
launched in.
AUDIENCE: Can this year,
like the coverage
will cover Hong Kong?
I cannot go through the
proposal before the
deadline this year?
REBECCA MOORE: I'm
sorry, did anyone
understand the question?
Can you repeat the question?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Because you said the deadline
for this year is August 1.
So if you are not running out in
Hong Kong, then I cannot go
for this year.
REBECCA MOORE: Yeah, if you
can be affiliated with a
nonprofit that is in any of
our currently supported
countries, that would be
the best approach.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
REBECCA MOORE: But next year
there will be more countries.
OK.
Any other questions?
Feel free.
Don't be shy.
Yes.
If you could go to the
mike please, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Do we come to you at
the booth if we're a nonprofit
who's interested
in the program?
REBECCA MOORE: Absolutely.
Please come talk to us.
We're happy to give you advice
on which applications are most
powerful, the kind of things
we're looking for.
But there's also good guidance
on that online.
Yes.
Another question.
AUDIENCE: A lot of the work
you presented, for obvious
reasons, is very focused on
environmental issues, except,
of course, the accessibility
becomes somewhat broader.
And so in my research life, I'm
a psychology and social
sciences person.
And there's all sorts of cool
things I can think to do with
Maps that isn't so much detailed
satellite analysis.
But boy, I could think of how
I could incorporate that and
do something cool.
So do you get a lot of
connection with non-profits
that are working outside of
traditional [INAUDIBLE].
REBECCA MOORE: Yes.
I mean, I wish we had all day
because there's so many
applications in the social
science area.
There's human rights,
humanitarian relief.
People are doing demographic
studies.
And if you go to our Earth
Outreach website and you look
under Success Stories and Case
Studies, you will see a lot of
examples that are in the social
science area as well.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm a developer from Brazil.
I'm getting the question via
cell phone right now.
REBECCA MOORE:
[SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
REBECCA MOORE: Or excuse me,
[SPEAKING PORTUGUESE].
AUDIENCE: In Brazil it's
[SPEAKING PORTUGUESE], right?
So my associate is asking if the
NGOs that want to apply to
this project, they need to be an
old and already established
NGO, or a brand new NGO
may apply in Brazil?
REBECCA MOORE: As long as
you're a registered--
and actually I know
in Brazillian
Portuguese it's ONG.
NGO is ONG.
AUDIENCE: My mind is always
backwards here.
REBECCA MOORE: Yeah.
It doesn't matter how
long you've been
a registered charity.
You can be new.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thanks a lot.
REBECCA MOORE: In fact, I will
say that we often find the
most nimble projects and ideas
are coming from those small,
small nonprofits.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I've been working on something
similar to AXS Map, getting it
off the ground in
the Netherlands.
So I definitely want to
talk to you later.
A question we've been getting
is how to ensure the
continuity.
Are you purely grant
dependent?
Or do you have some way to
get money from users.
KEVIN BLUER: This is in terms
of profitability?
Yeah, yeah.
There's a number models
we've been exploring.
And we can chat more deeply
offline for sure.
But yeah, it got kicked
off with the grants.
And then we've been looking at
some models of sponsored
venues, featured venues, and
also mapping days where people
raise money and perhaps--
like similar to kind of a
walk-a-thon style thing where
people raise money.
And some of that, essentially,
that money would go to the
organization to make it
sustainable as well as
obviously the other money
going towards
charities and so on.
So been exploring a number
of different models.
REBECCA MOORE: Good questions.
Yes?
REBECCA MOORE: Do your grants
touch anything political like
voter registration?
REBECCA MOORE: Oh, I might have
to get our grants person.
Do you know the answer
to that?
So as long as they're a
registered 501(c)(3).
And once you're 501(c)(3) that
means you're not doing
political advocacy, whatever.
As long as you meet that
criterion, yes.
You're eligible.
Thank you Tanya.
Tanya Birch-- you
should stand up.
Tanya Birch is a program
manager on Google Earth
Outreach and she spearheads our
grants program, including
the developer grants.
Other questions?
What are you going to do to
change the world today?
OK.
All right.
Thanks very much, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]